hallo herzlich willkommen meine todd
wells heute möchte ich euch endlich das
rezept für meine supreme vorstellen
ich hatte euch das jahr in meine
kartoffeln video gezeigt als diese
bamberger hörnla gemacht habe mit der
natur zusammen und jetzt habe ich
endlich die zeit gefunden
diese creme noch einmal für euch
abzufilmen und werde heute es zwei
varianten machen einmal die ganz normale
sour cream und einmal dass ich jetzt ein
experiment heute möchte ich eine rettig
afl creme machen so einen tipp die zwei
cremes oder dips die passen ganz gut
jetzt zum sommer für grillfeste ihr
könnt die saugen nämlich auch ganz gut
zu fleisch servieren oder einfach mit
etwas gutzumachen falten roth essen
ich mache einfach das grundrezept für
einen tipp aus quark und schmand und
dann verwandle ich die hälfte zu einer
verkrümmung und die hälfte eben zu
diesem rettig apfel
falls ihr eine ganz eigene creme machen
wollt dann benutzt einfach dieses
standards rezept und es könnte dann
einfach auf wandeln wie ihr das möchte
ich sehe euch jetzt einmal die zutaten
für das grundrezept braucht ihr 250
gramm speise gewagt da nehme ich immer
die mama stufe ihr braucht 200 gramm
schmandt salz und pfeffer eine charlotte
weil meine zu klein sind habe ich jetzt
zwei genommen und zwei zehen knoblauch
jetzt minister zuerst knoblauch und
schalotten schälen
die schalotten und die knoblauchzehen
werden jetzt gewürfelt wer keine karten
habt dann übrigens auch schon mal als
wieder nehmen aber schon locken so
einfach
angeschafft
dann nehmen wir die einfachen geht sie
in eure schuld habe ihr dann auch
anhören wollt dann kann seit der quark
rein und auch dass man dann gebt ihr da
etwa ein teelöffel salz rein dann noch
für guten halben teelöffel da machst du
einmal trug durch gerührt das ist
kinderleicht
die zeit die ich mir dass solche leute
zwei tipps machen möchte als im prinzip
wäre das jetzt schon so ein knoblauch
tipp aber wir wollen jetzt einmal ist
audrey machen und einmalig red ich tippe
deshalb die zutaten die ich jetzt für
die sauer cream benutze gelten jetzt für
die halbe portion dip also für diese von
aal bis grundrezept und falls sie jetzt
ein komplettes rezept machen wollt mit
einer packung quark und einer packung
schmandt müsste jetzt die mengen
verdoppeln
aber ihr seht jetzt auch gleich wie viel
aus dieser menge raus kommt also das ist
schon ein kleines schälchen von reichen
vier personen und das gleiche gilt dann
auch später für den richtig darauf als
ihr eine menge machen wollt einfach die
menge verdoppeln
für die st braucht ihr etwas zucker
lästig wenn ihr wollt kräuter und das
war's dann auch schon
gomez ich habe jetzt ein ganz normalen
wein würzigen essig da nehme ich jetzt
einen halb esslöffel davon
da schmeckt ihr am besten selber ab je
nachdem wie saures haben wollt und vom
zucker etwa ein teelöffel
ganz wenig und jetzt könnt ihr wenn ihr
wollt noch etwas kräuter leben ich hatte
vor kurzem schnitt noch da das habe ich
mir dann klein geschnitten und
eingefroren
da gebe ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen
die sau ist jetzt fertig und jetzt zeige
ich euch wie man aus der anderen hälfte
des grundrezept noch diesen rettig
appetit macht und da stelle ich euch
jetzt einmal die zutaten dafür braucht
ihr etwas rettig einen halben apfel und
etwas zitronensaft und halbierte dann
schädigt den dann noch das kerngehäuse
entfernen dann nehme ich mir den rettich
und macht da erstmal hier die wurzel weg
die schon so weit
und nehmen wir hier einfach so ein
kleines stück weg so wie so ein viertel
apfel in der größe der rettich wird dann
auch geschält
eigentlich kann man da auch meerrettich
neben dächer etwas würziger und schärfer
im geschmack aber den habe ich gar nicht
da deswegen nimmt jetzt einfach rettig
ganz normal es gibt da einen esslöffel
zitronensaft rein und dann werden der
apfel und startete ich einfach rein
gering
schön alles miteinander verrühren
und wenn ihr lust habt können wir jetzt
hier noch zwei abgespalten drauf geben
und hier noch etwas schnittlauch und
weitere jeder welcher dip das gerade ist
bei uns gibt es heute bei behandler und
ein putensteak als mahlzeit und da gebe
ich jetzt einmal die sau green und eben
den rettich strip mit dazu
da hatte ich dir passt ganz gut mit
fleisch und diese creme natürlich zu den
kartoffeln
das war's jetzt auch schon wieder
ich hoffe dieses rezept gefällt euch ich
habe da gerade überlegt einen karibik zu
machen
es hat sich mein mann nämlich gewünscht
dass es so eine curry sauce zum fleisch
hat da werde ich mir auch überlegen
lässt dann natürlich für euch filmen und
da sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder
falls ihr rezept idee habt für den dip
oder einfach einen wunsch und wendet
euch dann schaue ich was ich da machen
kann und wird es dann mit einbauen
jetzt wünsche euch viel spaß dabei beim
nachkochen danach machen und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
schmeckt